what does lm mean
does anybody know what lm means
can we suggest moves from miles of
danger
i think someone may have already
answered in case anybody in case nobody
answered
um please do not please do not suggest
moves
that is the answer
fritz adler 2079 good luck
lame mate yes
lm stands for lame mate
loser master
yes lm stands for loser master as well
does lm stand for danish gambit
lm does that stand for danish gambit
i think maybe it does
that works right
danish gambit
check oh no my queen
takes
rookie eight
this is theory this is all theory here
guys
i think knight gf3 is a playable move
there
can i use the queen's gambit
can i use the queen's gambit
uh maybe i can
maybe i maybe i can
okay
night at knight c5
now rook c1
is a skewer
so
and it gets your rook developed
so overall just a fantastic move
from my opponent
but he'd missed it oh dang
didn't see rook c1
dang dude
that sucks
oh now he sees it classic
classic
now he sees it
check
yeah this knight is kind of having
trouble developing
most people here i think play f3 but i
think i think knight f3
is playable
is it
i thought it was
right but our opponent plays knight c4
[Music]
oh yeah
listen
i'm thinking this right
am i not just winning a bunch of
material here
she moves
in material ways
it's all right it's all right
all right
that's not the correct lyric
it's uh that's the uh
that's the kiss that guy lyric right
the misheard lyric
mysterious ways
okay
now
do i take with
the bishop or
the rook
let's take with
yeah let's stick with the bishop
uh
stick with the rook
could have played check there
could he have
well the knight is pinned
so
maybe not
maybe not
down where
when
i don't see it
i don't see it
maybe both maybe both of you are drunk
or maybe i'm drunk
i don't
quite know
the f-file
he had the f-file check
maybe he did
maybe he did
or maybe he didn't
you're drunk okay
i'm glad we cleared things up here
i'm glad we cleared up the confusion
this square is covered let's get our
rook to the open file
perfect
i love putting my rooks on open files
i love it
we're up two pawns here
we're up two pawns
this is good
this is good news
um
we could go check
when i when i say this is check i mean
we're checking the rook
that's that's what i mean
he does have this move
and then he actually wins a pawn so
that's probably not good
okay
let's play bishop b5 we can now reroute
to this diagonal if it is beneficial
and we're over protecting d7 so now we
might be able to check the rook
and he still can't drop it back with the
king
there's no backing up of the truck he
needs to move the on-ramp
first
right
in fact if this move we also have knight
d3
he can't even go back because
that would just be a trade though
so 94 would obviously be much better
um are we actually threatening
to play this move
i don't are we
uh are we
it's close the king safety is very sus
very very sus here
this guy is good at not losing his rook
i agree
i agree
okay
check
you have to go there
this is not looking too hot guys
not looking
hot
at all
otherwise you get forked
so you have to come here
check
there
maybe not
let's start with
this move
now we're threatening knight e4
it's kind of hard to get out because if
you play king f2
there's knight d3
if you play this move
audience
the back rank it's it's this is what i
like to call the reverse back rank
it's when your back rank pawns checkmate
you but from the wrong direction
[Laughter]
the reason i didn't play rookie 3
straight away because i didn't like
rookie 3 king f2
and my rook is attacked
so is my bishop
here i think we're just gonna win
the rook
we're gonna we're gonna win his rock
hmm
i love
tasty rocks for breakfast
check
there is no king fork here no king fork
in this position
maybe there was a
better win
maybe there's a better move but
i think my way was pretty good the
danish gambit not taking us down today
bishop takes f7
we played we played perfect theory
knight gf3 it is a move here
the problem is if you take
what's the problem with taking
takes
and white is supposed to castle is that
correct you're not supposed to take
what what move are you supposed to play
king g8 knight c6
knight c6 too predictable i like king g8
then there's bishop takes f6
so what's the problem with taking
i know you're not supposed to take but i
can't remember
oh 95
totally forgot it yeah the 95 tactic
disconnection
and
yeah you're down the exchange